of killing his girlfriend's son is now
facing more charges police say brandon
tozlin killed four-year-old mason
dominguez and then stored his body in a
freezer it's a case the 80s now i-team
staying on top of our own david charns
here in studio with what happened today
david brian denise up until today we
knew investigators suspected brandon
tozland had done something to forward
mason domiguez to allegedly kill him and
now we know
what detectives believe happened to that
little boy
he is an incredible favorite to the
community and an absolute flight risk
given the
severity of what he is facing that's how
prosecutors described brandon tozlund in
court thursday the 37-year-old facing a
murder charge in the death of his
girlfriend's son four-year-old mason
dominguez police believe dominguez died
in december his body found in a freezer
in the home mason shared with his mother
sister and tozland in the northeast
valley he later told mason's mother that
he didn't get help because
the police would see bruising on
four-year-old mason's body
and he would be charged with murder as
the eight news now i-team first reported
detectives later found a suspected grave
in the backyard in court thursday
prosecutors revealed for the first time
how they say mason died this baby
four-year-old mason dominguez suffered
from a constellation of internal
injuries
to include multiple injuries to his
small intestine the deputy district
attorney also saying mason was covered
in cuts and bruises and had a bite mark
on his arm tillson's attorney asking the
judge to keep his client out on bail
pending trial in this case your honor
it's worth noting that the death
occurred in december and that rather
than fleeing the jurisdiction
mr toslin even by the state's reckoning
stayed in the jurisdiction for months
jordan tozlin to remain in jail without
bail and because of those new charges
that came down today from the grand jury
he is back in court tomorrow i'm david
sharon is live local now